So many people are just so ***ing obvious.
They don't even realize that when they box
me in or try to verbally put me in some
type of box or put Donda in a box
that they're really showing their level of ignorance.
They're putting themselves in a box.
and, you know, people can write, write, write all they want
but what are people doing?
And if there's anybody that's out there doing
they know how hard it is to actually do.
And I'm, like, a motivation of the doers.
If everything I did failed, which it doesn't,
it actually succeeds.
But if everything I did failed...
Just the fact that I'm willing to fail
is an inspiration.
People are so scared to lose that they don't even try.
Like, one thing people can't say is
they can't say I'm not trying.
That I'm not trying my hardest.
That I'm not trying to do it
the best way I know how
with what little information I get.
I like just doing these trains of thoughts.
Anyway, though, it's like it's kind of fun
because when this goes online
or whatever it is
It really matters...
And it, like, really doesn't matter... What matters
is, you know, the people who are sparked by it.
And the people who are, like, offended by it...
It doesn't ***ing matter.
*** you, you know?
Because it's about motivating the doers.
And anyone who wants to sit around and talk ***
they're taking too much time talking *** about it
instead of getting up off their ass
and following their dreams.
Because I'm here to follow my dreams.
You know, and help other people
follow their dreams and inspire people who are dreamers.
It's crazy that we live in a world
that if you're super positive...
and super creative...
that it's scary.
So what does that tell you about the mentality
of most people?
If you're scared of, like, positivity
and creativity?
Subtitles by the Amara.org community